[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition de votre journal local
voici les titres de ce mercredi 22 mars
c'est désormais une habitude chaque
année à quelques semaines du
baccalauréat apparaît le classement des
meilleurs lycées et dans les yvelines la
première place est détenue nouvelle fois
par un établissement saint quentinois
les détails à suivre dans ce journal le
soleil se font encore rares et le froid
persistant mais c'est déjà l'heure pour
les étudiants de trouver un job d'été un
forum spécial était organisée
aujourd'hui à montigny le bretonneux
de nombreuses entreprises du territoire
étaient présentes pour l'occasion
comptines jeux ateliers ou encore
rencontre jusqu'au 1er avril les plus
petits sont mises à l'honneur dans les
médiathèques de saint quentin en
yvelines l événement babillage permis
notamment d'accompagner leur
développement reportage enfin deux
journal je vous le disais donc en titre
je vous le disais en titre les
indicateurs de résultats des lycées sont
publiés par le ministère de l'éducation
nationale tous les ans au mois de mars
des indicateurs qui permettent à travers
un calcul plutôt complexe de réaliser un
classement des lycées avec notamment le
taux de réussite effectifs et le taux de
réussite attendu dans les yvelines vous
le voyez à l'écran pour la troisième
année consécutive c'est le lycée
trappistes de la plaine de neauphle qui
truste la première place il est suivi
par un établissement versailles est en
troisième position on retrouve le lycée
international de saint germain en laye
et puis de nombreux lycées saint
quentinois était présent dans le haut de
ce classement à ce propos écouter le
proviseur du lycée hôtelier de
guyancourt 1200 élèves et cinquième
cette année sous simplement fiers de nos
jeunes que nous accueillons dans notre
établissement qu'ils soient scolaires
apprentis aux stagiaires de la formation
continue et puis surtout très fier aussi
des équipes qui les entoure qu'ils
soient d'ordre pédagogique bien sûr mais
aussi tous nos agents qui oeuvrent à
leur côté pour leur réussite dans ce
nouveau bâtiment que nous venons
d'inaugurer à leurs services ne seront
numéro un au niveau des lycées hôteliers
au sens espacées au sens nombre de
jeunes
puis on va viser maintenant le numéro un
au niveau des résultats
évidemment ce classement est à
relativiser puisqu'il ne présage en rien
de la réussite personnelle de chaque
élève
non sans lien on en vient maintenant à
la recherche d'un job d'été un exercice
essentiel pour beaucoup d'étudiants mais
qui peut s'avérer compliqué sans
expérience professionnelle pour aider
les jeunes de nombreuses communes
décident d'organiser des forums spéciaux
comme cela les intéressés peuvent
rencontrer les entreprises de leur
territoire et les employeurs chercher
des profils estivaux intéressant c'était
le cas par exemple cet après midi à
montigny le bretonneux une soixantaine
d'offres étaient à pourvoir
reportage de miquel et demi d'euros et
victoire gaudin moi je recherchais un
mois pour que je puisse ensuite profité
de mes vacances d'été en août pleinement
avec un argent que j'aurais dû m'en
gagner pour trouver son bonheur martin
lorenzi 22 ans étudiants kinés à
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines a poussé les portes du pôle
jeunesse de montigny le bretonneux la
structure organisait ce mercredi
après-midi la sixième édition de son
forum jobs d'été à destination des
jeunes âgés de 16 à 25 ans en fait on a
une soixantaine d'offres d'emploi après
ça on a aussi des liens vers des sites
internet qui sont mises à jour avec des
offres qui sont réactualisées les quatre
sont candidats présents pour cet
événement également plus directement
échange avec neuf entreprises dans les
domaines de la restauration de la vente
de l'accueil ont encore de l'animation
certains n'ont pas hésité à donner leur
cv pour cet été ce mois je pense qu'on a
peut-être plus de facilités parce qu'on
est en contact direct avec les
recruteurs donc un premier lien qui se
fait que qu'on n'a pas quand on dépose
un cv directement tête à quelqu'un qui
ne connaît pas le recruteur il ne verra
jamais alors qu'ici c'est vrai qu'on a
un contact direct avec le recruteur et
que je pense qu'on peut peut-être plus
nous mettre en avant que juste sur le
papier en fait si vous avez manqué ce
rendez-vous le pôle jeunesse de montigny
le bretonneux peux vous donner des
conseils pendant ses heures d'ouverture
à 50 ans divine un autre forum jobs
d'été sont organisées à trappes mi-avril
dans le reste de l'actualité locale au
ministre de l'agriculture stéphane le
foll étaient en déplacement hier aux
mureaux il a visité la première légumes
riz bio d'île de france qui doit
alimenter à terme 700 établissements de
la région les précisions avec ce
reportage et des images divines première
1500 mètres carrés de locaux neufs
ici dans la première et unique légumes
riz bio d'île de france géré par la
société aca des bio les carottes sont
coupés nettoyer épluché puis mise en
sachet direction ensuite les cantines
scolaires
la destination finale de la consommation
dans toute l'ile-de-france est un
circuit court complet où on gère des
filières et des approvisionnements
contractuel avec des producteurs
nous transformons les légumes pour les
rendant prêtes à l'emploi pour la
restauration collective principalement
encore en phase de lancement la
légumerie inauguré il ya un mois
profitera bientôt à près de deux cent
mille élèves une initiative francilienne
pour favoriser l'approvisionnement local
et les circuits courts
ça nécessite comme un tout petit peu de
volonté politique
elle est là une mobilisation des
collectivités locales elle est là on
avait publié des guides en a mis en
place des plans alimentaires
territoriaux tout ça ça se structure ça
se met en place et c'est un beau message
aussi un qui consiste à dire et bien
l'approvisionnement
locale le manger local ça existe en
train de se faire 1500 tonnes de légumes
seront collectés transformer chaque
année en tout une cinquantaine de
producteurs vont bénéficier de ce nouvel
outil une aubaine pour faire face aux
problématiques structurelles qui touche
le secteur agricole c'est l'avenir de
mon exploitation j'en suis persuadé
aujourd'hui voilà on est à 50 km de
paris
c'est clair que c'est un avantage
indéniable par rapport à d'autres
régions de france qui n'ont pas un
bassin de consommation aussi important
dé à proximité et c'est une véritable
chance de pérenniser mon activité
agricole pour assurer le fonctionnement
de la légumerie une vingtaine de
personnes seront employées à terme dont
la moitié en situation de handicap
après versailles et mantes-la-jolie la
deuxième auto école sociale a été
inauguré il ya quelques jours ce
dispositif porté par le conseil
départemental des yvelines depuis
septembre 2016 permet à des
bénéficiaires du rsa et des chômeurs de
longue durée d'accéder à un permis de
conduire à prix réduit et ainsi
retrouver plus facilement un travail
maxime le maine pour le département a
suivi l'une de ses bénéficiaires
reportage
ça roule pour rosa maria après cinq ans
de chômage
elle a récemment décroché un emploi au
collège ravel de montfort l'amaury
pendant ses années de galère des
entretiens elle en a passé mais à chaque
fois elle se heurtait au même obstacle
je trouvais le travail mais je prendrais
pas parce que nos permis aujourd'hui le
permis est devenu indispensable pour
travailler en particulier dans les
filières à horaires décalés qui
représente la plus grande partie des
opportunités de retour à l'emploi pour
les bénéficiaires du rsa et les chômeurs
de longue durée
orientée par le territoire d'action
départemental de montfort l'amaury rosa
maria a donc étudié à l'auto école
sociale pendant environ un an
c'est un petit peu c'est dur des fois
combien dans le corps des traces je sais
pas bien les anglo français ont cédé
leur sac c'était plus dur plusieurs fois
elle a eu envie d'arrêter mais
heureusement l'équipe de l'auto-école la
re motiver et grâce à des méthodes
pédagogiques adaptés elle a pu obtenir
son permis mais le groupe de rosa je
pense qu'ils étaient ils étaient une
douzaine
du coup ce format là pour rosas a pas
vraiment fonctionné on a beaucoup
travaillé enfin bon on fait beaucoup de
cours et ensuite rosa elle a fait partie
de petits groupes comme quand vous venez
de le voir incline aux élèves qui sont
là soit on était deux ou trois on a pu
travailler sur l'écouté la compréhension
de la question puisque l après bleus
pouvaient pas relire la question une
méthode qui porte ses fruits grâce à
cette auto-école sociale répartis sur
deux sites déjà 27 personnes ont obtenu
le code 16 le permis de conduire et 6
ont trouvé un emploi et deux
déplacements toujours avec wade et
versailles qui poursuivent leur
coopération la ville et l'application
gps ont créé un partenariat l'an passé
ainsi la municipalité fait suivre toutes
les informations qui concernent les
travaux ou les routes barrées à wales
pour que ses utilisateurs en profite
hier se tenait une conférence de presse
pour faire le point sur ces avancées
nouveauté depuis quelques mois les
postes de police de la ville sont
équipés d'un dispositif leur permettant
de consulter l'application en en continu
excusez moi écouter sur ce sujet
le maire de versailles à l'intérieur de
l'espace ou s'être la police municipale
il y a en permanence un écran qui donne
les informations de wez mais évidemment
les informations qui nous concerne
directement au ca sur la ville donc on
voit que iliad est maintenant un usage
parce que certaines informations comme
elles sont données par les utilisateurs
vont quasiment plus vite que celles
qu'on peut avoir par les services la 28e
édition de la semaine de la presse et
des médias est organisée en ce moment
dans les établissements scolaires
l'occasion d'éveiller chez les plus
jeunes l'intérêt du journalisme et
développer aussi leur esprit critique
certains ont déjà pris de l'avancé comme
au lycée emilie de breteuil de montigny
le bretonneux
cinq élèves de première es ont monté
leur propre journal la gazette des
milles et une première pour
l'établissement nous les avons
rencontrés en pleine élaboration du
quatrième numéro rencontre et reportages
de camille lambert pas encore majeur
mais déjà titulaires d'une carte de
presse en première au lycée emilie de
breteuil ses élèves sont en pleine
conférence de rédaction
cinq amis qui ont créé leur propre
journal la gazette des mines sané
pendant les vacances dernière pendant
une petite période d'ennuis et donc du
coup avec guillaume et un camion s'est
dit qu'on allait créer le journal du
lycée parce qu'on aime beaucoup
journalisme et s'exprimer sur tout et
donc du coup en septembre on a commencé
à écrire et on a sorti le premier numéro
en inox croit on fait toujours une
interview une grande interview
donc pour le premier numéro c'était une
interview du rgo travers et nos peurs de
youtube à la politique
pour leur deuxième numéro en novembre
les adolescents ont questionné benoît
hamon et jean frédéric poisson
aujourd'hui ils finalisent leur
quatrième édition
au programme une quinzaine de pages sur
l'actualité avec un article sur les
violences policières
mais aussi culture avec la poésie
moi j'écris des poèmes choisi un thème
et à partir de ce thème là j'essaie
d'écrire ce qui me vient à l'esprit en
fait j'essaie de faire passer un message
à travers mes poèmes avec le 8 mars
comme stage ma femme j'ai écrit deux
poèmes sur la femme
donc j'essaye en fait de m'inspirer de
mon quotidien ou d'événements qui me
marque ou qui touche mon entourage pour
effectuer les recherches de la rubrique
actualités direction les sites des
grands médias
mais les apprentis journalistes n'ont
aucune envie de copier leurs objectifs
un journal par des jeunes pour des
jeunes on veut pas rentrer et non plus
dans les gros gros sujet parce que c'est
pas notre rôle est plus n'est pas
qualifié pour ça mais on dire quelques
mots c'est important puis rester simple
dans l'écriture est pas se prendre la
tête
vraiment pas je pense que c'est
important d'informer les jeunes qui
n'ont pas forcément l'envi de de
s'informer et comme dans chaque
rédaction il y a un directeur de
publication ils n'ont présenté
le sommaire est donc
donc j'ai donné mon accord il me demande
si je suis d'accord pour des interviews
pour des sujets d'actualité et donc en
fonction je leur donne mon accord mais
en général c'est le cas puisque ce sont
vraiment des élèves très sérieux après
validation ultime étape l'impression le
quatrième numéro sera tiré à une
centaine d'exemplaires disponibles au
lycée la gazette des milliers est
également à retrouver sur internet sur
le site de l'établissement
on referme ce journal avec l'agencé
locale de l'énergie et du climat qui
mène régulièrement des activités à
destination des particuliers des
collectivités
hier matin était organisé un atelier sur
le financement des travaux de rénovation
énergétique en copropriété face à la
difficulté de trouver des aides
financières
les copropriétaires se trouvent parfois
démunis cette matinée était là justement
pour les aider à trouver des solutions
et les accompagner dans leurs démarches
écoutez sur ce sujet l'animateur de
l'atelier les aides financières on se
rend compte que c'est souvent un point
de blocage
plus spécifiquement le plan de
financement et le financement
on se rend compte que certains
copropriétaires n'arrive pas à financer
soit ils n'ont pas les moyens
et les économies de pour financer ils
sont obligés de faire appel à des prêts
ou alors ils ne connaissent pas tout
simplement les mécanismes d'être
financières des différents dispositifs
on a vu aujourd'hui que les dispositifs
évolué très souvent chaque année c'est
la fin de ce 7 8 le journal prochaine
édition demain soir d'ici là bonne
soirée à tous
[Musique]